le festival des petites formes c'est un
festival essentiellement dédiée à
l'activité théâtrale donc l'idée en 2015
lorsque nous avons créé ce fait de ce
festival sous la houlette de sam kass et
kouyaté l'idée importante était de
stimuler la création théâtrale
martiniquaise mais de permettre qu'elles
soient
facile à assimiler et qu'elle met en
avant des des oeuvres théâtrales venus
de martinique mais aussi venus venus
d'ailleurs qui pourrait pas seulement se
jouer chez nous dans d'entropie 4 hir
mais aussi en extérieur
alors il ya eu des clins d'oeil au slam
clin d'oeil à la poésie et cette année
alors indépendamment de l'activité
théâtrale effectivement les les on va
dire des disciplines voisines du du
théâtre comme la poésie comme le slam ou
les lectures théâtrales ont été
on était associé au festival des petites
formes et cette année nous revenons en à
la lecture avec des lectures théâtrales
et puisque nous avons le plaisir et
l'honneur d'avant en invité koffi
quoi où les qui est un grand auteur
d'origine ivoirienne
nous allons recevoir aussi étienne
lepage qui est un auteur québécois
et puis alfred alexandre qui est aussi
le président de tessé caraïbes mais
aussi qui est un auteur martiniquais
alors 4e édition ses créations c'est
beaucoup c'est l'objectif du festival
c'est de stimuler la création alors on
peut dire que à la quatrième édition il
y a quatre créations martiniquaise ce
n'est par amiens nous en sommes très
heureux
il y à des créations qui qui nous
viennent aussi de la guadeloupe et des
créations un petit peu plus ancienne
mais elle date des 2 c ces neuf derniers
mois
et puis il y à une création que l'on
peut qualifier d' internationale puisque
c'est une prédation de nathalie virac
qui va d'ailleurs ouvrir le festival le
dernier arrivage de daniel qui mais qui
est un qui est un texte qui doit être
monté par hassane kassi kouyaté qui est
aussi l'homme il revient mais cette fois
ci en tant que l'invité d'honneur et
metteur en scène avec nathalie verra qui
est une comédienne guadeloupéenne tiji à
dakar et toute l'équipe autour et
martiniquaise sur le décor la création
lumière et s'éteint c'est un partenariat
aussi avec le l'institut français de
dakar